obligados a abandonar moscú los 20
diplomáticos checos volvieron a casa
todos fueron expulsados por el gobierno
ruso luego de que praga si eras él lo
mismo con 18 empleados de la embajada de
rusia pueden estar orgullosos de su
trabajo no hicieron nada malo
los diplomáticos fueron expulsados solo
porque la parte rusa reaccionó a las
medidas justificadas que tomó república
checa- cuando logramos dividir las
células de operaciones espías rusas
también los diplomáticos rusos abordaron
un vuelo especial para volver a moscú
praga los expulsó al tener sospechas de
que la inteligencia rusa había estado
involucrada en dos explosiones en un
depósito de municiones en octubre y
diciembre de 2014 en territorio checo se
cree que dos de ellos fueron los autores
y también del intento fallido de
asesinato en 2018 del ex oficial de
inteligencia militar ruso serguéi
skripal en reinounido la disputa con
república checa es una de tantas que
tiene rusia actualmente por un lado la
unión europea denunció al despliegue de
más de 150.000 soldados rusos en la
frontera con ucrania y el crime a la
región ucraniana anexada por mosco en
moscú le echó más leña al fuego
anunciando una serie de maniobras
navales que realizará del 24 al 31 de
abril en el mar negro aunque ya
empezaron el lunes ejercicios en el
ártico con buques submarinos y aviones
la comunidad internacional tiene los
ojos sobre rusia por la detención del
opositor alexéi navalni aquí en el
kremlin no le permite tener acceso a
médicos de confianza su deteriorado
estado de salud despierta preocupación
fue se inició una huelga
hace tres semanas por el mismo motivo
los ministros de exteriores de la unión
europea señalaron que se trata de un
gesto más del gobierno ruso que va en la
dirección incorrecta